Se você rotaciona uma bola em torno de um eixo e depois de outro, o resultado não é o mesmo que fazer as duas rotações na ordem inversa.
Hoje, no Qiskit na sala de aula, vamos ver o que essa bola tem a ver com computadores quânticos e um dos princípios mais famosos
da mecânica quântica: o princípio da
incerteza. Bem-vindo ao Qiskit na sala de aula, uma série de vídeos onde destrinchamos um conceito fundamental que você
pode encontrar em um curso relacionado à computação quântica. Cada vídeo é acompanhado por um módulo interativo com o link na
descrição abaixo, então não deixa de conferir. Hoje estamos falando sobre o princípio da incerteza de Heisenberg. Se
você já ouviu falar sobre isso, pode ter ouvido também a velha piada sobre Heisenberg: certo dia, ele foi parado enquanto dirigia e o policial perguntou: você
sabe a que velocidade estava indo? Heisenberg respondeu: não, mas sei exatamente onde estou. Isso é mais ou menos
o princípio da incerteza de Heisenberg em poucas palavras: você não pode saber simultaneamente a posição e o momento de uma partícula
com perfeita precisão. É frequentemente escrito assim: Δx × Δp é maior ou igual
a ħ/2, onde Δx e Δp são as
incertezas na posição e no momento, e ħ é uma pequena constante fundamental da mecânica quântica.
Heisenberg formulou essa desigualdade em 1927, quando imaginava como medir a posição de um elétron. Se
você jogasse um fóton nele para ver onde está, esse fóton inevitavelmente chutaria o elétron e perturbaria seu
momento. Isso não é apenas uma afirmação sobre medições perturbando um sistema — nos diz que há limites fundamentais
para quanto podemos aprender sobre a natureza. Esse é um exemplo de um princípio mais amplo chamado complementaridade, que
diz que certos aspectos da natureza são incompatíveis entre si e não podem ser observados
simultaneamente. Por exemplo, objetos quânticos às vezes se comportam como partículas e às vezes como ondas,
mas você não pode observar os dois comportamentos simultaneamente. A relação de posição e momento de Heisenberg cobria apenas um de
muitos conjuntos de características complementares. Essa incerteza inerente tem a ver com como enxergamos propriedades como
posição e momento na mecânica quântica. Em vez de pensar em x e p como variáveis ou propriedades intrínsecas
que cada partícula possui, na mecânica quântica posição e momento são operadores. Não são propriedades de um
sistema, mas coisas que você pode fazer a um sistema. Aprender sobre a posição de uma partícula agora requer que você realize uma
operação nesse sistema e faça uma medição. Essa operação pode afetar o resultado de outras
operações subsequentes. Como analogia, pense em um pedaço de madeira seca. Ela tem muitas propriedades, como
posição, tamanho, forma. Ela também tem a propriedade de ser inflamável e de flutuar na água. Se essa madeira fosse um
objeto quântico, essas não seriam propriedades que você poderia simplesmente conhecer a priori. Em vez disso, diríamos que são
observáveis — coisas que você pode aprender sobre o sistema se realizar alguma operação nele. Então você precisaria aplicar os operadores de
inflamabilidade ou flutuabilidade, o que exigiria realmente tentar queimar a madeira ou colocá-la na
água para ver se flutua. Agora, o resultado de cada um desses operadores depende da ordem em que você os aplica. Se
você primeiro testar a inflamabilidade, a madeira vai queimar virando cinzas e você não vai conseguir testar se ela flutua. Mas se você testar
a flutuabilidade primeiro, ela ficará molhada demais para queimar. Dizemos que os operadores de inflamabilidade e
flutuabilidade não comutam — a ordem das operações importa. Isso leva a um limite fundamental
para quão bem esses dois observáveis podem ser conhecidos sobre o pedaço de madeira, já que não podemos dizer com certeza se ela é
inflamável ou flutuável sem saber o contexto dessa medição. Claro, com um pedaço real de madeira,
você poderia cortá-la ao meio e testar ambas as propriedades simultaneamente. Mas você não pode fazer nada parecido com uma partícula quântica. Essa
analogia com a madeira é apenas isso — uma analogia. A incerteza é uma coisa exclusivamente quântica. x e p também não comutam,
e essa propriedade de não comutatividade é o que leva ao princípio da incerteza de Heisenberg. Em geral, quaisquer dois operadores
que não comutam terão seu próprio princípio de incerteza. A forma geral do princípio da incerteza pode ser
escrita assim: ΔA × ΔB
é maior ou igual a
½ vezes o módulo de ⟨[A, B]⟩, onde
esse colchete é chamado de
comutador, e é igual à diferença entre aplicar primeiro A e depois
B, e aplicar primeiro B e depois A. Esses colchetes angulares
indicam que você está tomando o que se chama de valor esperado do que está dentro — basicamente, se você fizer a mesma
medição muitas e muitas vezes, o valor esperado é o valor médio de todas essas medições. Hoje vamos
realmente testar e verificar esse princípio da incerteza em um computador quântico da IBM. Vamos olhar para três diferentes
observáveis de um qubit, mostrar que seus operadores não comutam e, por fim, provar que o
princípio da incerteza vale para esses observáveis do qubit. Primeiro, um breve aparte sobre uma forma útil de visualizar o estado quântico
de um qubit. Ele pode ser representado por um vetor apontando para algum lugar em uma esfera chamada esfera de Bloch. Abordei
isso em um vídeo anterior cujo link está na descrição, mas vou fazer um breve resumo aqui também. Aqui está a
esfera de Bloch. Cada vetor é parametrizado por dois ângulos, Theta e F.
O estado zero fica no polo norte e o estado um fica no polo sul. Uma superposição igual de 0 e 1 fica
em algum lugar ao longo do equador, onde F é igual à fase relativa entre as duas partes da
superposição. Então esse estado aqui seria igual
a 1/√2 |0⟩ + e^ |1⟩, onde φ é essa
fase. Quando medimos um observável do qubit, o resultado é sempre uma de duas opções, correspondendo aos dois
estados possíveis do qubit. Para o experimento que vamos realizar, vamos olhar para três observáveis e
seus operadores correspondentes: X, Y e Z. Quando você mede qualquer um desses observáveis, você obtém +1 ou
-1, com uma probabilidade para cada um que depende do ângulo entre o vetor do qubit na esfera de Bloch e
o eixo de medição. Como você pode esperar, Z mede ao longo do eixo Z, X ao longo de X
e Y ao longo de Y. Lembre-se de que estamos falando sobre observáveis porque, com um sistema
quântico, não podemos mais simplesmente saber coisas sobre o sistema sem medi-las.
E cada observável tem uma operação correspondente, porque medições requerem operações. Pode não ser óbvio, mas
acontece que as operações — chamadas operadores — que correspondem a cada um desses observáveis x, y e z são
rotações de π em torno dos seus respectivos eixos. Então X é uma rotação em torno de X, Y
em torno de Y, e Z em torno de Z. Para ver se esses operadores comutam ou não, podemos verificar se rotações
em uma esfera comutam. Se comutarem, o princípio da incerteza não se aplica e poderíamos conhecer X, Y e Z de um qubit
com perfeita precisão. Se não comutarem, seremos capazes de encontrar uma nova relação de incerteza para o qubit. Observe
o ponto nessa bola enquanto eu roto primeiro em torno de X e depois em torno de Y. Ele acaba
aqui. Agora vamos tentar na ordem inversa: roto primeiro em torno de Y e
depois em torno de X. Ele acaba aqui. Então definitivamente não comutam. Isso significa
que não podemos conhecer simultaneamente os valores exatos de X, Y e Z de um qubit. Teremos uma
relação de incerteza. Vamos passar por cima dos detalhes aqui, mas chegamos a três relações de incerteza diferentes.
Então temos ΔX × ΔY
maior ou igual a ⟨Z⟩; ΔY × ΔZ maior ou igual
a ⟨X⟩; e ΔZ × ΔX maior ou igual
a ⟨Y⟩. Então o produto de quaisquer duas dessas incertezas é sempre maior ou igual
ao valor esperado do terceiro observável. Vamos usar o Qiskit para ver o que
acontece quando tentamos medir tanto Z quanto X do estado zero. Medir Z é fácil — é a chamada base padrão.
As medições no computador quântico são sempre ao longo de Z por padrão. Mas para medir X precisamos realizar o que se chama de
mudança de base — basicamente rotacionar a esfera de Bloch para que X aponte para cima onde Z costumava apontar. Para fazer isso,
usamos um gate Hadamard. Então o circuit quântico completo vai parecer assim: medimos em Z, aplicamos o Hadamard
e depois medimos em X. Se usarmos o sampler primitivo do Qiskit para rodar esse experimento muitas vezes, terminamos
com um histograma de resultados de medição que se parece com este para Z
e assim para a medição em X. Como você pode ver, medimos o
qubit no estado zero ao longo de Z com quase 100% de certeza. Mas
ao longo de X, não sabíamos basicamente nada sobre o estado do qubit — foi medido como zero ou um com igual
probabilidade, o que significa que nossa incerteza em X era tão grande quanto pode ser. Isso nos dá
uma ideia dessa troca de incertezas, mas podemos fazer um pouco melhor no nosso computador quântico. Podemos usar uma
primitiva do Qiskit chamada estimator para encontrar os valores esperados dos nossos observáveis X, Y e Z, e a
incerteza em cada um. Vamos tentar para o estado apontando na direção +X na esfera de Bloch. Vamos usar o estimator
para calcular as incertezas em x e z para esse estado e o valor esperado de
y. Com esse estado, obtemos esse resultado do Qiskit. Quando tomamos o produto das duas
incertezas em X e Y, vemos que, como esperado, ele é maior que o valor absoluto
do valor esperado de y. Mas isso foi apenas para um estado específico. Queremos ter certeza de que essa desigualdade
vale para todos os estados do qubit. Então vamos usar o estimator novamente, mas desta vez vamos pedir que ele varredure os valores de um
parâmetro e encontre os valores esperados em cada valor de parâmetro que fornecemos. Aqui o parâmetro que queremos varredura
é o ângulo Theta na esfera de Bloch, para que possamos verificar a desigualdade para todos os estados do qubit que estão sobre
esse arco que intersecta o plano XZ. Quando fazemos isso, obtemos um gráfico em função do ângulo Theta. A curva vermelha
é o produto das duas incertezas e a curva laranja é o valor esperado de y. Como esperado,
o produto das incertezas em x e z é muito maior que o valor esperado de y. Mas isso não era
tão difícil de satisfazer a desigualdade porque o valor esperado de y era tão baixo — era zero para todos os estados sobre
esse arco. Vamos fazer uma varredura similar pelos valores de Theta, mas em vez de varredura no plano XZ, vamos definir φ igual a π/
4, então estamos olhando para os estados do qubit que estão sobre um arco diferente na esfera. Aqui vemos que a desigualdade é
testada um pouco mais, já que a curva laranja e a curva vermelha estão mais próximas, mas a vermelha está sempre acima da laranja
e o princípio da incerteza ainda vale. Ainda não verificamos todos os estados, mas esperamos que você esteja começando a entender
a ideia. Há uma incognoscibilidade fundamental sobre quaisquer dois aspectos complementares de um sistema
quântico, incluindo esse qubit que temos usado. O princípio da incerteza nos força a confrontar o fato de que não importa
o quanto tentemos, não importa quão inteligentes sejam nossas medições, nunca saberemos tudo com perfeita precisão.
Não tem como fugir disso, de verdade. Se você não acredita em mim — ou mesmo se acredita — te desafio: acessa o módulo
com o link na descrição e tenta superar o princípio da incerteza. Obrigado por assistir e até a próxima!